Are the powers of the Nikyu Nikyu Fruit the
most OP in One Piece? We break down the Paw
Paw Fruit and its user, Kuma, and uncover
his tragic past. Then, we explore the shocking
reveal of Stussy, the clone of a former Rocks
crew member, and the implications of her vampire
Zoan Devil Fruit. Could Sanji's father, Judge,
have made her in an attempt to create the
perfect kid soldiers? Find out in our latest
breakdown of One Piece!
**Hook 2**
The One Piece manga just showed us the amazing
true powers of the Paw Paw Fruit. It might
be the strongest Devil Fruit in the story
and it could even give its user the ability
to copy other Devil Fruit powers. After eating
it, the user can repel anything they touch.
Not only that, but it's one of the few Devil
Fruits that changes the user's appearance
permanently. They get paws on the palms of
their hands, which help them repel anything
they come in contact with.
And I mean anything: We've seen it used for
some incredible things. It can be used to
teleport people, protect them from powerful
attacks, and and in maybe the most famous
scene of One Piece, it is used to expel all
of Luffy's pain from his body, which Zoro
then takes on in his stead. And now, Eiichiro
Oda, the author of One Piece, has finally
fully explained how its powers work. Instead
of just being able to repel any physical object,
like a sword or a person, the Paw Paw Fruit
additionally also has the special ability
to repel IN-tangible things as well, like
it did with Luffy's pain. Pretty cool, right?
That means that you can also use this fruit
to expel all KINDS of things. It can remove
memories, feelings, and thoughts from someone's
body and turn them into something you can
touch. This is usually in the form of a big
bubble that looks like a paw. For example,
Zoro stepped into this one containing luffy’s
pain. And in this new manga chapter, there
is a sphere containing someone’s entire
memories. This fruit is so powerful--you can
repel anyone, no matter how strong they are,
and travel incredibly fast to wherever you
want. It can also push out someone's emotions
or pain and then use it on someone else or
store it somewhere. But the best part is,
this fruit can do even more than what we know
so far. In this chapter, we find out that
Bartholomew Kuma, who ate the Paw Paw Fruit,
was not only Vegapunk’s test subject for
the pacifista and the seraphim, super advanced
clone soldiers developed for the world government,
but Vegapunk used Kuma’s special devil fruit
ability to do all sorts of other experiments
too.
And being able to take something invisible
like imagination and turn it into a real thing,
sounds a lot like Vegapunk's theory about
how Devil Fruits are made. Supposedly, they
are created out of people's imaginations.
So it's possible that Vegapunk may have used
Kuma's Devil Fruit power for his experiments
with Devil Fruits. The best evidence for this
are actually this elephant, this racoon and
this dog. Because none of them are real animals,
but objects that have eaten a Devil Fruit—a
sword that ate an Elephant Devil Fruit, a
teapot that ate a Raccoon Fruit, and a cannon
that can become a dog. We know that this new
technology was created by Vegapunk, but how
can an object eat a Devil Fruit? Well according
to this new explanation of Kuma’s abilities,
it should be possible to push out the intangible
power of a Devil Fruit and put it into a new
object. so you take the elephant fruit, have
Kuma extract the power inside and place a
sword inside the sphere. So you take the Elephant
Fruit, have Kuma take out the power inside,
which would look like one of his paw shaped
spheres, and put the sword inside the sphere.
So just how Zoro could absorb Luffy’s pain,
the sword would absorb the devil fruit power.
If that's true, then there's no argument that
the Paw Paw Fruit is the best Devil Fruit
in One Piece. But we didn’t only learn a
lot about this devil fruit in chapter 1072
- we also learned a lot of new things about
its user.
Now in case you don’t know for whatever
reason, Bartholomew Kuma is not only the person
who ate the Paw Paw fruit, but he also has
been one of the most mysterious and influential
characters in the entire story for Luffy and
the straw hats. He has gone full circle from
one of the most terrifying enemies of the
straw hats, to one of their biggest allies
and protectors. Here’s a quick recap:
The straw hats first met Kuma in chapter 483,
after they just barely beat the ancient giant
oars, who had been transformed into a zombie
by Gekko Moria, one of the seven warlords
of the sea, who worked for the world government.
Luffy was still knocked out from the fight
and the straw hats were all tired from the
battle, when Kuma suddenly showed up on the
island. It turned out that he was another
warlord of the sea, who had been instructed
by the government to kill anyone who saw Moria's
defeat. In order to protect Luffy, Zoro and
Sanji offered themselves as sacrifice. This
led to my favorite scene of One Piece, where
Zoro took on all of Luffy's pain in exchange
for his freedom. We also found out that Kuma
was actually a person who was turned into
a cyborg by Dr. Vegapunk, which was a great
hint to what happened on Egghead Island and
Vegapunk telling us the truth about Kuma in
chapter 1072.
A short time after their first encounter,
the straw hats run into Kuma again, during
the sabaody archipelago arc. After punching
one of the celestial Dragons, the highest
crime a person can commit in the One Piece
world, Kuma arrives together with admiral
Kizaru and Sentomaru, again mirroring the
current events in the story. And while Kizaru
is kept busy by Rayleigh, the Straw hats are
absolutely decimated by Kuma, as Luffy has
to witness every last of his crew mates vanish
before his eyes. At this point in the story,
it really seems like Kuma is the worst enemy
the crew ever had to face.
After their major loss at Sabaody, the truth
about Kuma slowly came to light. It turned
out that Kuma was trying to protect the Straw
Hat Pirates from Admiral Kizaru by sending
each of them to the ideal place to improve
their abilities during the time skip. He had
lost much of his free will when he became
a cyborg weapon for the government, and that's
why he had attacked the Straw Hats on Thriller
Bark. Yet, he still retained enough of his
humanity to save them and later protect their
ship, the Thousand Sunny, while it lay unguarded
in a Sabaody harbor during the time skip.
Kuma wanted to help the straw hats because
he was one of the three founders of the revolutionary
army, lead by Luffy's father, Dragon. Kuma
and Dragon are also friends with Vegapunk,
so Kuma let the scientist experiment on him
and turn him into a weapon for the government.
Although we still don't understand why this
is the case. With his daughter Bonney about
to step into his bubble of memories however,
it seems very likely that we will be getting
a tragic Kuma flashback in the next chapters,
that will answer a lot of our questions. Make
sure to subscribe to the channel, if you don’t
want to miss the breakdown of that.
Before he became a cyborg or joined the revolutionary
army, Kuma was actually the king of a country.
Jinbei tells us, that Kuma got his title of
‘the tyrant’ for being a cruel ruler.
However according to his daughter Bonney,
that is not true. And honestly, everything
we have seen of Kuma, including his flashback
with Vegapunk in chapter 1072, makes it look
like Kuma was actually a really good person
with a tragic past. We know that it’s tragic,
because Vegapunk tell Bonney that he promised
Kuma not to tell her the truth about why he
became a cyborg, because it would be too painful
for her to hear. So whatever it is, it sounds
like we should prepare a box of tissues once
we see what really happened to him. One thing
that we do know, is that Kuma is part of a
special race and that . And while it hasn’t
been confirmed yet officially, it is very
likely, that Kuma is a member of the almost
extinct lunarian race. The only other known
member of this race is King, the right hand
man of Kaido, who just like Kuma, was heavily
experimented on by the government. The lunarians
were a race of winged humans, that lived on
top of the red line before the world government
was established, who were known as gods. They
have dark skin and are able to generate fire
from their bodies. And there are a few pieces
of evidence that kuma is a lunarian.
He has the same dark skin as King. He was
used as the prototype for the Seraphim soldiers,
who all have Lunarian wings, fire and skin.
Luna means moon in Japanese, hinting at the
fact that the lunarians were the advanced
civilization that lived on the moon, that
we saw in a cover story with Enel. If Kuma
was a lunarian, it would also explain why
Kuma hated the world government so much and
why he formed the revolutionary army with
Dragon, just how king joined the dragon Kaido.
In addition to that, just like the other warloards,
KUma has an animal theme. Kuma in Japanese
literally means bear. And as one really smart
reddit user noticed, the Asian black bear
in Japanese is called ツキノワグマ tsukinowaguma,
which literally means "**ring-of-the-moon**bear".
Apparently this is also the inspiration for
the pokemon Teddiursa which has a crescent
moon, Ursaring who has a new moon, and Ursaluna
which has a full moon on his head.
And as Vegapunk is arguing with Bonny about
Kuma, we actually see the real Kuma in chapter
1072, who has teleported himself to the foot
of the red line, trying to climb to the top.
He is shot down by marine soldiers, but he
seems determined to reach his goal, whatever
that might be. Hopefully we will get the flashback
for Kuma soon.
But there was obviously another major reveal
in this chapter that we have to talk about:
Stussy of the CP0 agency has just betrayed
Lucci and Kaku. AND it is revealed that she
is a clone of a former Rocks crew member.
The very first successful clone made by Vegapunk’s
team of crazy scientists. AND Stussy seems
to have what looks like a vampire zoan devil
fruit, that just looks absolutely badass.
And all this has opened up even more questions
we need answers to: For example, is Stussy
the secret female member of Vegapunk’s MADS
science group that we saw in the cover the
other chapter? Or was it maybe the original
stussy that got cloned? We know for a fact
that as the clone of a rocks pirate, Stussy
must be incredibly strong. But then, why didn’t
Sanji’s father recognize her during the
wedding ceremony? They were sitting at the
same table. The next question is: Is stussy
the mysterious person, that Vegapunk contacted
to help them? Because she sure did help by
knocking out Kaku, but then again there could
still be someone else. Also, if stussy is
a perfect clone, that actually begs the question
who else in the story could be a clone. Anyone
could be really. Maybe Luffy is a clone too.
Who knows with Oda. Then we have to ask: Where
is that original stussy of the rocks pirates
now? It seems like the correct answer seems
to be this stunningly beautiful lady here,
the mother of Edward Weevil. Her name is Bucking.
While Stussy is introduced as the clone of
Miss Buckingham stussy. The name seems to
match. Also, Bucking claims that her son is
the biological son of whitebeard, which would
make sense if they were in the same pirate
crew. And while she doesn’t look it now,
if she looked the same as stussy does in her
youth, I could absolutely see Whitebeard going
for her. Weevil is a very interesting case
anyways. He could be a clone too, after all
he has those stitch marks that Franky has
too. Or he could be Whitebeard’s actual
son. During his introduction, Kizaru comments
that he definitely has the same power as a
young whitebeard.
So now we have two versions of a rocks crew
member. One seems to be on Vegapunks side,
who made her in the first place. While the
original seems to be working with the government.
I love how this entire situation suddenly
got super intriguing. And there is actually
one MORE thing i want to talk about with stussy
that one of the awesome members of my subreddit
brought to my attention. Have you ever realized
that she looks very very similar to Sanji’s
mother? same eyes, same hair, but shorter,
same lips. Stussy was cloned by the mads science
group. And Sanji’s father judge was a member.
Could judge have made another version of Stussy
for himself, to create his perfect kid soldiers
with the DNA of a former rocks member? It
is also interesting that Queen hates Judge
so much, which he reveals to Sanji during
their fight. After all they were crew mates.
And we also know that Queen deals really poorly
with being rejected by women. It happens with
both Hiyori and one of the Geisha’s during
the fight with Sanji, who saves her life.
Could it be that Queen hates Judge for having
married a version of Stussy, a woman that
he fell in love with? Who was part of their
crew as well?
As I said more questions than answers. Instead,
let’s talk about Garp setting out to fight
blackbeard. If you havent heard my thoughts
on the crazy last chapter, then make sure
to check out that discussion right here. Thanks
for watching.